[Music]
and not what i meant news
not what i'm saying submitted by boohoo
bobby
a bomb threat at home depot turned out
to be something else
well was it a surprise birthday party
clogged toilet yeah right glock toilet
jackass dude did you see that episode
where he took a [ __ ] that was the
funniest part
when he went into the hardware store and
he just started taking a [ __ ]
at the display [ __ ] up i hope they
paid him fat and then they're like
excuse me and he goes i'm almost done
the crazy part was him prepping for it
so what was he eating like he was trying
to get his stomach all riled up so he
can poop
all right laxatives yeah but the first
time before he even made him to the
hardware store he actually [ __ ] himself
in the driver's seat yeah because he
couldn't he's like oh
oh no oh [ __ ] it's too soon and he
already [ __ ] himself
round two was when he finally made it
see all the cameraman trying to [ __ ]
they're all getting
one camera guy or like the crew guy he
would always oh
yeah wait so they went in there with
cameras and everything
yeah cameras probably weren't that small
they're probably like these having a
hell of a probably like this
yeah so and home depot employee called
9-1-1 and said that they had a customer
that
might have made a bomb threat and
someone ran up to them and said hey you
need to leave
you need to leave the building there's a
bomb in here and that they said it three
times
and then someone there told the staff
that they overheard someone
in the restroom say y'all need to get
out of here because i'm fixing to blow
it up
oh i told you i knew it was a toilet
dropping bone
yeah so that turned into a whole bomb
threat thing because
cops kicking down the stall you're just
trying to take a nice pool and he's just
with the newspaper
dropping bombs blow this place up but
yeah that made headlines
because people were saying like oh you
know warning was mistaken for a bomb
threat would you take that
very literal you wouldn't i think yeah
you gotta go by tone because i i'm
american so i understand slang and stuff
but i can
see if like an immigrant or something
but this is kansas
with a they're all they're probably all
white absolutely true in the bathroom
though yeah what's your tone like we're
all about to play with this place upper
he said he's fixing him or if the guy
that was taking a dump looked like a
stereotypical terrorist or something
what if he had it
yeah like a trench coat or something
he's got a bunch of supplies
for no reason oh he looks like steve
buscemi with a trench coat and he just
looked crazy
yeah i'm about to please just crop side
the four guys just cross side
i'm about to blow this one up yeah
that's true
oh cause the terrorists they have out
there are like uh like the oklahoma city
bomber
yeah yeah yeah yeah that serial killer
yeah like doc martin's on
it's like oh [ __ ] they just just bought
everything at a hot topic wait so did
they ever
catch the guy no yeah so they did find
the person they were just saying like
in the restroom this isn't
misunderstanding like did the whole bomb
squad and they were all just suited up
wow i know right damn
well isn't it the same thing on planes
you can't say like oh like
you can't say the word bomb you can't
say fire there's a fire in a pub any
public places
oh really well that's going to be [ __ ]
up because all the kids these days are
like that's fire
that's fine you can't yo you can't yell
fire in a pub and our generation was
that's bomb
yeah that's true that's lit no i can't
see that anymore at the airport
i know i had to tell isaac i'm like we
can't say
here like i have to tell him like really
quiet because i don't want to get in
trouble and he's like
mom we can't say at least he's smart
because if he was dumb he's like
you can't say bomb yeah that's the [ __ ]
you do
yeah i'll be like don't say this wait
why can't i say that i'm like oh my god
dude oh
man or i'm like okay don't make it
obvious but the person over there and
you're like where
yeah i'm like don't do that i don't do
that i go like this
i wait give it a beat there we go
even more suspicious i see them who says
that though who walks in somewhere i'm
fixing to blow it up like think
fixing is because in texas they say it
too and i'm like fix
it but casey because he's from texas i'm
fixing to go hunting
yeah yeah we're fixing we fixing to do
some dope videos today
and then in texas they say chunk instead
of chuck
that one like blue one chunk of
something
like a c-h-u-n-k yeah it's like how many
chunks out of you
it's chunky i'm like what that is
basically
that trash away it doesn't feel good
chuck chuck it's like you gotta chuck it
chunk it feels like throw
chunk just sounds like fat fat chunky
yeah i want my brownies
yeah chunk is like like i'm a chunk it
and then
it just falls chuck is it feels like a
throw
that was a bad throw how do you think
all the chucks of the world feel maybe
they don't like it
chuck oh yeah dude i don't know if i
ever met a chuck that's a kansas city
name i wish you just kind of blew it up
like a short for something charles oh is
it trouble
are you [ __ ] liar
i don't know you see [ __ ] so much i
said charles at the same time so i think
i had heard it before
i'm not afraid of terrorist attacks in
america
when i should be because there's so much
like news about it
i like the pauses because we all react
but i should be i hear that because it
feels so safe huh yeah i'm more afraid
of like
gangs and crackheads biting me and so
you could call that terror
that is terrorism though but like i mean
you know like foreign
threats certain things do freak me out
like what was it um
the dark knight getting shot up in the
movie theater oh that was scary what was
that
like mass shootings and stuff in a movie
theater went in the movie theater and
just like shot the place up
so i was at a movie theater uh probably
last year maybe two years ago or
something
and um it was probably like middle of
the day saturday you know getting that
matinee price because i'm cheap and
there's not that many people in there
and there's one guy in the corner like
there's there's tons of roasts was he
having a jack like jack
jack get his backpack oh and i'm like
all right and
i was with my girlfriend at the time and
he said over there he kept playing with
his backpack
and just kept playing with his backpack
and like through the movie through the
theater he's dressed kind of weird i
think it's a summer day and he's wearing
like a coat
oh no and you stayed there the whole no
no i bounced outside
oh but [ __ ] i know you okay i went up
and i [ __ ] choked him out
uh but i was scared and now when i'm in
theaters because of the dark knight and
because of weird [ __ ] like that i'm
always [ __ ]
well now they check the bags they don't
let you take backpacks yeah you
shouldn't who the [ __ ] needs a backpack
in the movie
hey snacks yeah illegal also buy the
snacks there that's true
that's true you never used to go to the
movies after school yeah kids i guess
but this guy's a grown-ass man kids i
get i think homeless people
they used to go they go in there to
sleep or whatever too
no way yeah that's expensive the the
matinee
the cheap one yeah it's true yeah i
think first movie i mean not like four
bucks
all homeless are like dirt dirt poor
they just don't have a home
a lot of people go to the gym yeah they
go to the gym they take a shower there
all that stuff yeah yeah that's scary
you know where i did think about
terrorism though is when i went to
europe that's when i first started
thinking about it
yeah i felt it there too why because
um it was during the time that europe
was getting attacked so we were in paris
and then this was specifically happened
we were going to go on the eiffel tower
and then like you just see like all the
tanks and [ __ ] in the mid like the
military guys with like ak-47s or
whatever
they're around like that all the time
yeah and then and then
like i was telling him i'm like [ __ ]
like this is the perfect time for us to
die like if they come in
because it's like a national monument
you know like the eiffel tower and we're
like going up to the top and i'm like
that's why i get looking around the
whole sky i'm like it looks clear
i'm sorry i feel like you have props to
our law enforcement here
so i follow a couple of law enforcement
pages
ig's and they still they kind of show
behind the scenes of how they like keep
security
and like before like the super bowl or
any big parade or anything like that
they scope it out they run rehearsals
like they're on communication like three
or four days beforehand
and behind a lot of secret [ __ ] there
are always snipers ready to go
so if some [ __ ] some [ __ ] pops off
they're ready to just stop it
immediately at almost any like a justin
bieber concert there's probably
like three or four snipers especially
after the ariana grande contest yeah
they're ready all the time and what i
what i'm really grateful for is
in america because our law enforcement
is so dope they can do all this in
secret
without you feeling like you're unsafe
but in europe i don't know if their law
enforcement or military
is as sophisticated as ours yeah or even
different some people might might be the
same yeah so they just have to be there
like
maybe that's what deters maybe yeah
honestly because i was going to say like
seeing all that
made me feel safer and then oh really i
feel
safer because i'm like cool they got
this [ __ ] covered
i'm paranoid at everything airplanes
coming down here like you see how lazy a
lot of tsa people are no
i'm like you're supposed to be stopping
bombs from getting through this little
there was a gun that went through i'm
sure i'm sure yeah i could get anything
we've been through the immigration in
mexico after i went through the
immigration mexico
like tsa are [ __ ] bomb they're like
fbi
dude they're [ __ ] good they're doing
the best they can okay
there's people that are like in uniform
and you have like excuse me where's the
immigration line they're like
[Laughter]
they made the tsa look good here
everywhere else feels relaxing though
it doesn't feel like whole [ __ ] like i
gotta [ __ ] be careful
i i like it i like seeing everything out
in the open
when i see it out in the open i feel
like they're losing control
yeah like i feel the same i feel like
there's a speaking yeah i feel like oh
[ __ ]
it's a war zone yeah i agree but maybe
that's just because we approach american
state like we said we never see
it around yeah because imagine you're
trying to take a romantic picture with
casey
at the eiffel tower and just a big ass
tank in the back it kind of ruins the
picture right that kind of looks dope
it's like we're in a war movie it's like
why are you taking pictures of a war
zone
man the funny thing is why would they
need a tank like
terrorists aren't going to bring a tank
like why would you need a tank
i could have made up the tank part i
don't know maybe that's just how they
have they have like
these and stuff okay there's armored
humvees and stuff yeah every time we
have to spend like a
super long ass time to get through
security to get like go through the
metal detector get our bags
x-rayed and all that i'm like good i
will spend all the time i need at least
no but you're tsa pre
what a nerd that means you don't like it
no so i'm talking
tower or something no yeah i'm talking
about that like oh i see i say the
statue of liberty or like all these
monuments you know how many things we've
smuggled through that we didn't even
know
she smuggled a razor a razor blade and
we made it to mexico she's like oh [ __ ]
yeah i was like oh my didn't even do
their job having a [ __ ] knife geo's a
killer
don't mess with me
[Music]
you